اذا اوكرانيا ليس لديها وقت تضيع تخوف
امريكي من هجوم روسي شرس متوقع باواخر
الربيع في اوكرانيا واشنطن تسابق الوقت
لقلب المصالح لمعركه كيافو لصالحك عبر نقل
الجيش الامريكي لمعداته الى ساحه المعركه
لتدريب القوات الاوكرانيه بوتيره سريعه
طبعا قبل الهجوم الكبيره المتوقع ضد روسيا
تقول هنا
بان مئات الدبابات والعربات المدرعه في
طريقها الى اوكرانيا بما في ذلك لاول مره
ثماني مركبات مدرعه يمكنها مد الجسور
والسماح للقوات بعبور الانهار واشنطن لا
تريد فقط كسب معركه الربيع ضد موسكو انما
تعمل على تمكين القوات الاوكرانيه
بالاسلحه والذخيره اللازمه لاستعاده
الاراضي التي خسروها في كامل الشرق
والجنوب في الفتره الماضيه المخاوف
الامريكيه مشاهدينا قابلها تاكيد روسي
بعدما اعلنت الاخيره ان اوكرانيا على وشك
مواجهه احداث عسكريه خطيره ليست لصالح
كياف والظروف الجويه الراهنه لا تصب في
صالح الجيش الاوكراني لان استخدام معدات
عسكريه ثقيله كما هو معروف على طرقات
موحله لن يكون سهلان وبالتالي هذا الامر
سيكون صعبا ايضا على القوات الروسيه